zurück bei bild live mit einem knall hat
interview polens präsident paul du da
rechnet im gespräch mit bild vize paul
ronzheimer mit olaf scholz und dem
umgang der bundesregierung mit dem
ukraine krieg ab und nimmt dabei kein
blatt vor dem mund
glauben sie der deutsche kanzler olaf
scholz hat angst vor putin
ich bin erstaunt über die ganzen
gespräche die geführt werden mit putin
im moment von kanzler scholz von
präsident emanuel makro diese gespräche
bringen nichts was bewirken sie sie
bewirken nur eine legitimierung eines
menschen der verantwortlich ist wie die
verbrechen die die russische armee in
der ukraine begeht er ist verantwortlich
dafür
er hat die entscheidung getroffen die
truppen dort hinzuschicken ihm
unterstehen die befehlshaber wladimir
putin hat jemand so mit adolf hitler
während des zweiten weltkriegs
gesprochen hat jemand gesagt dass adolf
hitler sein gesicht wahren muss dass wir
so vorgehen sollen dass es nicht
erniedrigen sie ist für adolf hitler ich
habe solche stimmen nicht gehört
[Musik]
bevor der deutsche kanzler die lieferung
schwerer waffen angekündigt hat sprach
er in einem interview von einem
möglichen atomkrieg er hatte und er hat
immer noch angst davor teilen sie seine
bedenken
wenn wir angst vor den russischen
atomwaffen haben sollten wir uns alle
gleich ergeben denn wenn präsident putin
rausgeht und sagt jetzt werden wir
atombomben auf die ukrainische
hauptstadt werfen wenn ich brav seid
wenn ihr nicht den russischen
einflussbereich bis zum atlantik bis
lissabon ausweitet sollen wir dann alle
angst bekommen und die richtlinien von
putin ausführen und seine politik in
ganz europa realisieren weil wir angst
vor seinen atomwaffen haben ich möchte
daran erinnern das nukleare potenzial
der welt und der nato
russland zermalmen falls es benutzt
werden sollte es ist natürlich eine
katastrophe für die welt aber russland
weiß das ja auch
sie haben kürzlich kritisiert dass die
deutsche regierung ihr wort gebrochen
hat panzer zu liefern welche versprechen
wurden gebrochen ist das problem
mittlerweile gelöst
wir haben damit gerechnet dass die
waffen auch nach polen geliefert werden
und wir würden gern die ältere version
annehmen und dann vielleicht in zukunft
auch modernisieren auch mit hilfe der
deutschen industrie wir würden gern
dafür bezahlen doch wir haben damit
gerechnet dass wir die ältere version
der panzer bekommen soweit ich weiß
haben wir gar nichts bekommen
jetzt auch zugeschaltet nach diesem
interview pauli sind wirklich heftige
setzte bei diesem interview gefallen
unter anderem auch der satz hat jemand
so mit hitler gesprochen wie wahr so die
stimmung bei dem interview wie hast du
das erlebt
angie du da der polnische präsident war
sehr selbstbewusst in dem interview dass
man sowohl an den aussagen wie da war
auch wie er sich dort verhalten hat und
den satz du ansprichst der hat natürlich
eingeschlagen heute im politischen
berlin in paris aber auch in der ukraine
ich habe mit vielen gesprochen darüber
was andere da dort gesagt hat denn das
muss man sich ja noch einmal klar machen
das ist ein angriff des polnischen
präsidenten gegen die achse deutschland
frankreich gegen micron gegen scholz die
ja immer wieder mit nadine putin
telefoniert haben die immer wieder sagen
wir müssen verhandeln die immer wieder
sagen es geht nicht anders und du da
stellt sich komplett auf die seite der
ukraine auf die seite von siemens geht
er sagt das bringt so alles nichts wir
müssen erstmal diesen krieg gewinnen und
es zeigt sich die spaltung europas in
dieser frage das wird in den nächsten
tagen sicherlich die ukraine debatte
bestimmen was der polnische präsident
hier im bild interview bei uns gestern
gesagt haben
hornissen zu sagen du bist von polen ein
weitergereist bis jetzt gerade in der
ukraine bis in lemberg eingetroffene
kannst also dort alle reaktionen in der
ukraine auf dieses knallharte interview
auch spüren erfragen lasst uns gemeinsam
noch einmal in einige aussagen
hineinschauen zum beispiel als so
gefragt hast du da glaubt dass scholz
angst vor putin hat das sind hier
reinschauen
ich bin erstaunt über die ganzen
gespräche die geführt werden mit putin
im moment von kanzler scholz von
präsident manuel makro diese gespräche
bringen nichts was bewirken sie sie
bewirken nur eine legitimierung eines
menschen der verantwortlich ist wie die
verbrechen die die russische armee in
der ukraine begeht er ist verantwortlich
dafür
er hat die entscheidung getroffen die
truppen dort hinzuschicken ihm
unterstehen die befehlshaber wladimir
putin hat jemand so mit adolf hitler
während des zweiten weltkriegs
gesprochen hat jemand gesagt dass adolf
hitler sein gesicht wahren muss dass wir
so vorgehen sollen dass es nicht
erniedrigt ist für adolf hitler ich habe
solche stimmen nicht gehört
da eben noch mal dieser satz hat jemand
so mit hitler gesprochen hatte ich das
gewundert dass er da so klar gegen olaf
scholz eben gewettert hat
da ein mich nicht gewundert dass der
polnische präsident gesagt hat
möglicherweise in der intensität was er
dort am ende dieses satzes sagt man
hätte mit hitler so nicht besprochen und
auch nicht darüber diskutiert ob er sich
erniedrigt fühle das ist ja genau das
was makro zuletzt in der letzten woche
gesagt hat dass man eben russland dass
man putin
entgegenkommen müsse und das ist die
klare gegen positionierung hieraus holen
aber er spricht dort eben die sprache
vor allem auch der und aline die haben
nämlich große sorge dass der westen
wegen sanktionen wegen der
kriegsmüdigkeit wegen der debatten wegen
des sommers jetzt der der ukraine druck
machen könnten und sagt ihr müsst jetzt
verhandeln ihr müsst aufhören mit diesen
krieg und dann eine territoriale jahr
niederlage einstecken würden denn das
würde bedeuten wenn man diesen
bedingungen russlands entgegenkommen
dass zumindest der gesamte osten
verloren wäre und das ist auch das muss
man so klar sagen in der ukraine nicht
durchsetzbar und auf see lenski kann das
nicht durchsetzen selbst wenn er wollte
das würde wohl sein politisches ende
bedeuten und immer wieder paul die angst
vor einem atomkrieg die so lebens ja
auch der kanzler ins feld geführt hat
auch darüber hast du mit polens
präsident oder gesprochen
wenn wir angst vor den russischen
atomwaffen haben sollten wir uns alle
gleich ergeben denn wenn präsident putin
rausgeht und sagt jetzt werden wir
atombombe auf die ukrainische hauptstadt
werfen wenn ich brav seid wenn ihr nicht
den russischen einflussbereich bis zum
atlantik bis lissabon ausweitet sollen
wir dann alle angst bekommen und die
richtlinien von putin ausführen und
seine politik in ganz europa realisieren
weil wir angst vor seinen atomwaffen
haben ich möchte daran erinnern das
nukleare potenzial der welt und der nato
würde russland zermalmen falls es
benutzt werden sollte es ist natürlich
eine katastrophe für die welt aber
russland weiß das ja auch
russland weiß dass auch und die ukraine
ist das land es darunter leidet unter
dieser lähmung unter dieser angst paul
du bist jetzt in ländern nach diesem
interview wir werden dort diese worte
wahrgenommen wie wird dort auf die sorge
die angst sie so sehr lebt die auch
davon abhält schneller mehr waffen
endlich zu liefern wahrgenommen
in der ukraine in lemberg ist scheinbar
normales leben eingekehrt hierbei der
krieg ja ohnehin immer nur temporär zwar
gibt es hier noch eine ausgangssperre in
der nacht aber jetzt tagsüber wenn ich
mich umschaue ähnlich wie in kiew er
merkt man wenig davon aber die menschen
sagen natürlich wie kann das sein dass
deutschland uns nicht mehr unterstützt
wie kann das sein dass olaf scholz nicht
schneller und schärfer und härtere
waffen uns schickt wie kann das sein
dass wir nicht so unterstützt werden und
das ist das was die menschen wollen eine
bessere unterstützung für ihre soldaten
insbesondere gerade im osten wo es um
alles geht
erschreckend dass wir immer noch genau
darüber sprechen wie schon seit beginn
des krieges das in die ukraine sich hier
aus deutschland nicht genug unterstützt
fühlen du bist jetzt wieder für uns in
der ukraine und bleibst vor ort und wir
werden dann im laufe des tages und im
laufe der woche natürlich auch immer
wieder zu dir kommen um dort aus der
ukraine die neuesten nachrichten zu
bekommen vielen dank erstmal an dich für
den moment